what's going to get a flat white
how much is that 290.
do you take gas cutting
gas coin the new the new crypto for for
gary's economics the youtube channel
it's it's gascoigne it's it's worth 147
pounds 20 minutes
more than a flat white
let me have a go
i hate to break it to you boss
worth nothing
gone down to zero yeah
okay
you keep the coffee
we're gonna do one on crypto
crypto bitcoin nfts everybody's talking
about them if you take away one single
message from this video i want it to be
this all of these investments are
extremely risky and it's completely
possible that you can lose 100 of any
money you invest in them but right now
these things are being advertised on
buses they're being advertised on
footballers jerseys there's millions of
people all over instagram and youtube
telling you they've made thousands of
pounds on it probably even your friends
are saying this every single video i
post on this channel
i get scammed comments saying you can
make loads of money on bitcoin all of
these things come together to give the
impression that these are safe reliable
investments nothing could be further
from the truth okay i'm in touch with
gambling organizations and they're
seeing a massive increase of people with
addictions to crypto trading and massive
losses from it i've had friends
personally lose enormous amounts of
money you need to understand these are
super dangerous investments and you can
lose any money you put in
next we're going to talk about what
cryptocurrency actually is
cryptos like bitcoin are an unbacked
monetary system
what that means is they're not backed by
anything real
look if you buy apple stock you own a
part of those apple stores and some of
those apple products if you buy tesco
stock you literally own a part of those
supermarkets if you buy a house you get
house you can live in if you buy gold
you get a little bar of gold if you buy
bitcoin all you have is a bitcoin you
can't exchange that legally for anything
it gives you no legal ownership rights
nothing could make this more clear than
the situation of nfts non-fungible
tokens in this case celebrities like
john terry and paris hilton sell little
pictures of monkeys on the internet that
look a little bit like them sometimes
for millions of dollars
people who buy them often think it gives
them the legal copyright rights to these
pictures
but then they find actually they don't
legally own anything all they've bought
is a little token on the internet saying
they own it with no associated legal
rights
it's the same with bitcoin it's the same
with crypto you don't own any real
assets you don't have any legal rights
it is a totally unbacked monetary system
i know exactly what you're thinking
you're thinking regular money is exactly
the same
central banks are printing hundreds of
billions of pounds and dollars and
they're devaluing the pound in your
pocket they're devaluing your savings
they're devaluing your wages and you're
looking for a safer place to invest that
is 100 sure enough said the same thing
on my channel but listen just because
money is a bad investment that doesn't
mean you should start buying made up
internet money
look if some guy came to your city and
said look your money is a bad investment
you should buy
this brand new internet money i've
created would you do it look the vast
majority of the owners and creators of
these cryptocurrencies are very very
wealthy people and they're convincing
you to buy their internet points with
your real money and they're using that
real money to buy your mom's houses that
is what's happening here
and listen i know there are people who
are not going to want to hear this
message there are people who might even
be getting angry there are people who
are invested in bitcoin who desperately
desperately want it to go up listen i
know that
and i know we've created a country here
where ordinary hard-working young men
and women can work every hour of the
week and save up every penny and still
not even be able to buy a house
listen i know we've created a society
where it's almost impossible for people
from poor backgrounds to become rich and
i know if you create that society then
ordinary people are going to be
desperately looking for another
alternative a way out
and i know that these very wealthy
people are using those fears and
insecurities to try and get you to buy
into these points on the internet
and they're taking your real money in
return for that
listen this is not a way out this is a
trap
but you know what upsets me more
we live in a country where ordinary
families are getting poorer generation
after generation
the homeownership rate is collapsing
people are being pushed further and
further into debt
we've got a billionaire chancellor who's
raising taxes on ordinary people whilst
cutting taxes on millionaires and
billionaires and while all this is
happening some of our smartest brightest
young people have been convinced that
the only thing they can do against this
is trade pictures of monkeys on the
internet
listen there's a real fight going on
here okay the rich and the super rich
are getting richer and richer and taking
the real resources that the families of
these countries need
ordinary people are getting poorer
they've got the money the power and the
newspapers the only thing we've got is
that there's more of us and we're
smarter
the only way we can protect the
financial position of ordinary families
in this country is by coming together
look if you're a crypto trader out there
we need you come together and help us
fight back
look
these guys are telling you a dream here
it's a dream that if you trade their
queens and their monkeys on the internet
then you can be a millionaire
and while you're doing that
they're gonna take our wealth and our
houses
it's the trap
don't fall for it
so what do you do instead
number one you educate yourself
i've got a video on this channel about
the basics of investing i've also got a
video explaining what is wealth
understand what real wealth is and what
you can do to protect yourself and your
family
number two is push back man don't accept
a system that is so unequal
push for better wealth distribution and
for a tax system that taxes billionaires
on a higher rate than you pay your tax
and number three is share this message
we need to get people together if we're
gonna push back and make things better
anyway
i've been looking for an investment
that's safer than bitcoin and um
i think i might have finally found one
keep watching
losing his job